Kostantino: my vision is 20 by 1,300, which means what you see at 1,300 feet. I have to be 20 feet away from to see. That means that I do live in that magnification world, and that magnification world for me is powered by apple. I have a macbook pro and an imac that are both connected to a 78 inch screen located about 18 inches away from my face.
Kostantino: All software is completely up to date on the Mac OS system as well as on Ios. I do use an iphone and an ipad. 90% of the time it is the iphone.
Kostantino: I do primarily use Apple's accessibility technologies and settings. Although I do have some third party apps and software that I do use. I don't anticipate having to use anything beyond the apple settings. Today
Kostantino: we are engaging with the Macbook Pro and Zoom here, and although there are some differences between accessibility settings in Ios and Macos.
There will
Kostantino: more than likely be a situation where I hit the physical limitations of the at and the settings, in which case I might have to use my low tech devices, which include my glasses. Pardon me as I stretch for one of my others. I have 16 pairs of glasses, yellow, orange, and green. I do use a traditional magnifier at times, as well as some
concave and convex glass lenses.
Kostantino: I may or may not use my monocular, which is traditionally used for long distances or far away distances, but I use them when I'm looking at certain images or text that might be too small. I may or may not use my desktop 5 x or 10 x magnification lamps.
Kostantino: Although I don't think that I will need to because we are in Mac OS
Kostantino: 2 final quick caveats before we move forward. The first is that we are using zoom on Mac OS today, and unfortunately, when I invert my colors, which I usually am inverted about 90% of the time, you won't not be able to see those inverted colors, you will see the default layout. I will do my best to try and tell you what those colors look like, and what that contrast appears like.
But.
Kostantino: you will not be able to see anything other than a quick pop-up model that says color contrast on or off.
That will be your clue, but I will also let you know.
Kostantino: Secondly, there's a variety of different ways of magnifying. I've counted over 20 I use 3 more than any of the other ones, and there are 2 additional modes of magnification that you will not be able to see. One of them I don't use as much as the other, and that one, of course, is using the option. Command 8 key, which will magnify the entire screen
Kostantino: again. I will do my best to describe to you what is on my macbook crow screen at that time. So onwards and upwards
Kostantino: today I'm thrilled to be working with fable. That's an understatement, and I am taking on the role of reviewing up skill. I am looking at this learning platform and the courses, because I happen to be a learning manager who has been given access to the demo and the appropriate credentials which I've used to sign in
Kostantino: the objective today is to look around and explore as much as possible. See how usable and understandable the upscale site is.
Kostantino: and providing an overall rating on how the experience was
Kostantino: of note. I will not need to go through the entire course. The course has a variety of dummy content. This is more about the experience, and being able to navigate.
So that being the case.
Kostantino: I'm just gonna quickly hit my control option. Command 8 so that you could get a look at what the popup looks like invert display color on or off.
Kostantino: I'm in the default. Look right now.
Kostantino: Everything is white for the most part. We have a little bit of grey out on the background, because there is a white pop up that is very, very, very bright for me.
Kostantino: The good news is that I know from my time with fable engagements, that we have some great typography. So when it comes to scaling and being able to read things it is very, very well done. Kudos to the fable design and dev team, of course.
Kostantino: So what I now have is a black screen with really bright white text on that black again. I'm not overly looking at the magnification right now. I'm just trying to get a sense of what my contrast looks like.
Kostantino: which is amazing.
Kostantino: Because we are in safari. I'm really happy. I will be able to use both my pinch to zoom functionality as well as command plus minus. If I do need to use my option, command 8. I will let you know and tell you where we're at, so
Kostantino: I can see here
Kostantino: that we have
Kostantino: little bit of a plus.
Kostantino: very interesting. I just hit command plus a couple times, and the responsiveness of the site really changed.
Kostantino: and we seem to be locked into very
Kostantino: small window. That's a little bit bigger.
Kostantino: So it's responsive on my command, plus which is great welcome to fable upscale. I love this typography. I really really like the font. It is so
Kostantino: magnification-friendly again. Great job! So we have some content.
Kostantino: All right. So I just used command plus twice there. If I come out of it.
Kostantino: It's not scaling back the way that it should be very odd behavior.
Kostantino: I'm gonna try and command plus in try and do the best that I can with my pinch to zoom.
Kostantino: Oh.
Kostantino: okay, I think I touched maybe the video.
Kostantino: but I could quickly press the space bar to stop down here. Looks like we've got some blue on the black.
Kostantino: It's not so bad because it is a little bit of a brighter blue and as I hover over I'm very happy to see a hover state change, which is great.
Kostantino: I'm also able to see that there has been a color change on the button itself, meaning that it is likely actionable.
Kostantino: That being the case, if I wanted to start the tour, I probably could.
Kostantino:  But I'm gonna assume that for the sake of experience, I could turn on the video on and off as I just did.
Kostantino: I would be able to magnify to see
Kostantino: some of these settings. The problem is
Kostantino: that I would have to temporarily come out of my inverted contrast. And just a side note. My invert settings are classic invert, which inverts everything on the screen as opposed to smart invert, which doesn't invert media, icons, images, logos, etc., etc.
Kostantino: I can definitely see a nice bright red as I'm hovering over these icons.
Kostantino: I would look to magnify them a little bit more. But you can now see, or I can now see, that at the bottom of the screen it's all white. If I come back into my inverted classic
Kostantino: colors, then we've got the white up here, and that kind of blinds me with some of this content. The other comment that I would make is that
Kostantino:  It looks like
Kostantino: we've got some kind of
Kostantino: fluorescent green, but it it looks more like a fluorescent peacock green, maybe. And it really doesn't contrast well against the background.
Kostantino: One thing that I'm gonna mention right here is that because we're in the video. And the way that videos work. All of the text in the vigil is definitely pixelated for me. When I see pixelation, it, it actually vibrates the text. So
Kostantino: that is definitely different text and a different magnification than with the typography that I've spoken about up at the top. So assuming that I just want to get out of it, I could just
Kostantino: click anywhere and hit escape, which was great.
Kostantino:  I am going to quickly. Just come back here. And the one thing that I'm gonna say is. I really liked the way that this responsiveness on the site is working. Now
Kostantino: there is my
Kostantino: fable logo, which I'm pretty familiar with.  I've gotten used to this kind of
Kostantino: mustards.
Kostantino: greenish kind of shade that we have on the site. I prefer to see it be a brighter yellow or a brighter orange, but I can appreciate that. It's not just about me. It is about so many other users.
Kostantino: There is our hamburger, which is great.
Kostantino: And one thing that I can see right off the bat. That is much easier if I come back out by using my command minus.
Kostantino: and then quickly shrink.
Kostantino: I can see that there are a couple of images which means that I may or may not have a little bit more difficulty separating those images. It kind of looks like one for me. There is a very tiny sliver of black, but that might be the same photograph.
Kostantino: What I do like about the responsiveness, notwithstanding the pop-up that we just have to deal with with the introduction video is, if I do come back and hit my command plus keys.
Kostantino: Then we've gotten into a very streamlined look.
Kostantino: There's definitely been a trend towards the simplification of websites. I'm a very big fan of that trend. I'm not overly interested in content or images that don't inform me. I'm more about the text and the information.
Kostantino: What I do like is that again, this has taken that single kind of page format which I really really like.
Kostantino:  I also see a somewhat
Kostantino: thin outline around what may be one of the courses within upscale, or at least that's what I'm thinking.
Kostantino: The challenge for me is that the picture is not inverted. This is classic invert, so everything should invert. I don't know why that setting is like it is.
Kostantino: but if anybody should know
Kostantino: it's fable, we should not be overriding the accessibility settings of the user. So in my case.
Kostantino: I am looking for classic invert, and I expect everything to invert.
Kostantino: so it looks like we've got different sections.
Kostantino: Oh. up here towards where the picture is. I really don't see any type of outline when it comes to outlines and focus.
Kostantino:  it should be beyond just color. So it's great that I can actually see a line
Kostantino: in addition to the color.
Kostantino: Sometimes I would like to see lines that are maybe dashed or much older, so that they could really let me know that of course I am on actionable content.
Kostantino: But this simplicity is really really wonderful.
Kostantino: I very quickly am able to understand that I am
Kostantino: top right, hamburger, top, left logo, single column, and the ability to use my pinch to zoom
Kostantino: courses is a little bit creamish, but that's okay.
Kostantino: my active courses, nice, big, bright old white. I'm a big fan of 21 to one.
Kostantino: It looks like we've got some longer words here. So I'm just gonna
Kostantino: command, plus. it looks like that's the most that I could really get to means a little bit more. Leaning in
Kostantino: my accessibility journey.
Kostantino: I see the word Beta. I think I see some blue in the background
Kostantino: again. It's okay. But this blue against the black doesn't contrast as well as maybe something like, you know, a bright yellow or a bright orange.
Kostantino: So I was able to look at my active courses. Very scalable when it comes to the typography, and being able to really kind of ramp that up a little bit.
Kostantino: We've got this kind of
Kostantino: brownish, mustardy yellow
Kostantino: shade, that appears. I would absolutely like to see that replaced with like a very, very bright orange
Kostantino: that may or may not cause some contrast issues, because that would typically be a dark blue or a link blue.
Kostantino: But again.
Kostantino: I'm able to
understand that
Kostantino: really, really bright white circle. I don't understand
what that looks like. So I'm just gonna invert color contrast out
Kostantino: all right. I've now inverted out of my classic and color contrast.
Kostantino: It's still gray. This is all gray. It's still gray when I move into the black which I've just done now it's a whiteish gray with more. I
Kostantino: I really am not able to see that at all. I can see that it's a circle. I can see that it's bright.  I think that I had seen the word badge.
Kostantino: Yeah. badges. So that might be a badge, and if it is a badge. Then
Kostantino: then I should be able to see that badge. Maybe it's gray, because
Kostantino: no badge has been earned, in which case maybe you could just use the words, no badge, or you would maybe just have text there saying, Earn your first badge.
Kostantino: That would be a little bit of a positive incentive as well.
Kostantino: I'm gonna come down here to this section.
Kostantino: That's my command, plus
Kostantino: yeah, very responsive, which is great.
Kostantino: I'm really a big fan of Dom's that made sense and that are not huge. Of course we know the bigger Dom is, the less responsive of site might be which absolutely impacts the ux.
Kostantino: So far I could say that I'm really impressed. There is definitely some more content down here. Looks like we've got another course
canoe
Kostantino: pitch to zoom gonna now, plus
Kostantino: to the most that I can learn about accessibility. I am so thrilled at how wonderful our font and typography is on this particular page.
Kostantino: So I'd continue to deal with
Kostantino: that content. Got this yellow line here, which I want to.
Okay.
Kostantino: overall progress. Alright. So that is my progress bill, which is great.
Kostantino: I don't know as we go through the Progress, what that might look like. Looks like. We've got all of these courses that I can engage with.
Kostantino: I really really like the perceivability and understandability. There's not a wall of text
Kostantino: I'm able to very
Kostantino: easily and succinctly. I just wish that I could really get to just a tiny bit.
Kostantino: So there's my option command, plus. yeah, the typography at this level, which is probably sitting at around
Kostantino: 6 or 700% give or take.
Kostantino: it is really, really clean and crisp.
Kostantino: I can see my manicure here, which means that I have an actionable. So I'm now going to read the contents
Kostantino: and just
Kostantino: how to create mobile apps that work
Kostantino: well for users.
Cool
Kostantino: 18
Kostantino: to lose. Okay? So I know that these are dummy links. Oops.
Kostantino: Let's come out with command, minus a little bit more.
Kostantino: I'm just gonna try and get back to.
Kostantino: We have 2 elements up here. Great. So it's a little bit interesting up top. I've now got 2 white
Kostantino: words and
Kostantino: going to try and read them.
Kostantino: Yeah. So if I now come out command minus once I am able to see
Kostantino: no
Kostantino: dashboard and courses.
Kostantino:  But if I
Kostantino: if I try and scale that
Kostantino: up
Kostantino: now the Hamburger has disappeared.
Kostantino: and I've got a user option in the top
Kostantino: here, I can tell, because I've got a hover state change.
Kostantino: We have options here.
Kostantino: Right? So.
Kostantino: yeah, very interesting scaling. The responsiveness seems to
Kostantino: to disappear. If I get too far
Kostantino: magnified. If my command plus prompts move towards higher levels of magnification. The responsiveness of it is a little bit choppy, and that means that I'm not going to get the level of magnification that I need to be able to read things quickly.
Kostantino: It's easier to see that there's 2 tabs dashboard and courses. I'm going to quickly get up here
Kostantino: and see if I can come back up to
Kostantino: the Hamburger
here.
Kostantino: So it looks like once I select the Hamburger. Everything on the right hand side also disappears. So
Kostantino: oh.
Kostantino: so now in the Hamburger. we have got 4 elements. And
Kostantino: see, I'm just
Kostantino: okay. Dashboard courses, preferences. Logo.
Kostantino: Okay? So what happened then?
Kostantino:  2.
Kostantino: All of this are on the left.
Kostantino: Only way I'm gonna be able to try and see any of that is with Pinch to zoom. Because if I'm using my command, plus
Kostantino: that was one click from where I was one click back. I now see this left navigation menu definitely needs some attention paid to that.
Kostantino:  This sense
Kostantino: was horses, which was kind of queenish.
Kostantino: See? I can't
Kostantino: really can't get there with just the pinch to zoom.
Kostantino: Well, there's the beta again. I think my accessibility journey. Maybe.
Kostantino:  take the course.
Kostantino: Can't really see. I'm gonna assume that that looks like the combination of grays that I saw in the circle.
Kostantino:  bookmarks. Okay? So I'm gonna come back here.
Kostantino: Try and get to the singular column back up here. And
Kostantino: yeah, these are just the 4 that we saw earlier dashboard forces, preferences and log out right? So
Kostantino: everything that's on the left over there that I'm supposed to be looking at like my bookmarks and whatnot
Kostantino: is not accessible under certain magnification, so that would definitely create some challenges for me. What I really do like again, is the simplicity I like being able to come into a particular course.
Kostantino: I know that I am actionable.
Kostantino: Oh, okay, I thought that some of the links were disabled, but it looks like I've now gotten into the course. which is kind of cool.
Kostantino: What I'm going to try and do is
very quickly.
Kostantino: Oh. bear with me here.
Kostantino: just using my option. Command 8. All I can really see is the tip of my arrow
Kostantino: zoom. Apple changed these just a month or so ago. Follow over. So now I've enabled my Hubber text. Now, what that is going to allow me to do is try and quickly
Kostantino: navigate around and start to use my hover text. you will see that my hover text setting which engages when there is a mouse over, and I hold down command
Kostantino: populates a
Kostantino: what you see as a bright yellow background with black text.
Kostantino: For me it is a dark blue with a bright pink outline. The Times, New Roman font is a bright white, and that is set at 228 pixels or points. And if you compare that to 12 points, it's a factor of 19 or around 1,900%.
Kostantino: So when we talk about Wicc and the minimum requirements for 200 magnification and responsive design and and whatnot.
Kostantino: I'm well past that
Kostantino:  the big issue that happens a lot with hover text is, once you go
Kostantino: past a word that might have 5, 6, or 7 characters in it, and you've got 2 words or a longer word. It doesn't
Kostantino: respond. The way that hover text should.
Kostantino: I can see at the bottom here in a kind of pencil eraser, pink
Kostantino: a link that would take me somewhere. I can see that that's actionable by the color contrast.
Kostantino: What I can't see is the start of the content.
Kostantino: So what I have to do is I have to stay perfectly still over that area
Kostantino: and then start to scroll up.
Kostantino: to start to get to the top of the content.
Kostantino: What happens is, I then have to now go down. and sometimes words don't fit properly. I know that this word is introduction, but there's no N on the end of it.
Kostantino: All of the content is probably gonna do this, which means that all of this content could be very quickly fixed. It's not a difficult fix to address the way that hover text
Kostantino: scrolls.
Kostantino: And it's really not the end of the world. But it is the end of the world when you're dealing with an enormous amount of content on a site, and you have to keep on starting at the bottom, scrolling up to the top and then going down to the bottom. Very bad. Ux, and it really doesn't help me understand that content that much.
Kostantino: We have no hover text over any of the image. I'm hoping that all text would be there. I'm sure that it would.
Kostantino: It's our progress bar. So now I think that I can appreciate.
Kostantino: let's have a look at it. So if I see a very horizontal long bar like that. That should be my progress bar. So command minus to come out.
Kostantino: I do have a responsive button there. like the fact that the text is white in there at least.
Kostantino:  We've got
Kostantino: number of things down here
way too much gray content
Kostantino: over here. It's discoverable with hover text, but gray on black, grey, on white. Never a good thing. Always very difficult to deal with, and most of the time I'm just resorting to my upper text.
Kostantino: Looks like we've got
Kostantino: some kind of button here that sounds available
Kostantino: all right. You can see that I'm moving my mouse, but you can also see now that hover text and the touch points the touch.
Kostantino: Is not scaling properly. Looks like the button is now over the digital accessibility section.
Kostantino:  down here. We've got the pencil eraser pink. Now you're seeing what happens a lot
Kostantino: right if I'm trying to do this quicker, and I quickly scroll too much, while now I've over scrolled, and now I have to try and find my page
Kostantino: placement again. which means that I have to. and out of that magnification start up at the top. There was the learning button
Kostantino: and
Kostantino: both the introductory courses. So that looks like we've got a whole bunch of
Kostantino: alright. Why are there? Why is there some white screen readers.
Kostantino: Okay. if we have 2 different titles or 2 different sections in this particular course.
Kostantino: we should really deal with more of the other elements of contrast. So about digital accessibility. And further down, screen readers. that text could definitely be bigger and bolder
Kostantino: when we say, contrast too often contrast is considered just the color contrast when the definition of contrast really deals with the juxtaposition of 2 or more elements or considerations
Kostantino: being compared against each other. So in this particular case, I'd like to see more line spacing character, spacing, word, spacing.
Kostantino: font, selection, font, size, boldness, weight, italics. There's a lot more to contrast than just color. So
really making a point of helping me understand that those are
Kostantino: 2 sections.
Kostantino: Now, you can see why I'm going to get out of that configuration because there's just too much to try and get around
Kostantino: if I'm using my tab ability, I can see that
Kostantino: I have that kind of mustardy, yellowish
Kostantino: green if you want
Kostantino:  which is great.
Kostantino: I really like the fact that there's not an enormous amount of content that's forcing you to have to cycle through your tab key.
Kostantino: And now shift tab back. which is great.
Kostantino: So it looks like we've got what I think was activity. I think on the right hand side I saw the word status which would tell me like how far I'm going into each one of these. I'm just gonna randomly pick
Kostantino: start learning so that we could start at the beginning. Something is happening. There's some kind of oh. okay.
Kostantino: one zone. So
Kostantino: it looks like we are in the course
Kostantino:  going to.
Kostantino: I'm back to my single layout
Kostantino: because I saw a whole bunch of colors there.
Kostantino: now, you can see
Kostantino: I will be able to
Kostantino: boat
Kostantino: alright. So we have a hover state change over each of these links. But I don't really see any type of focus indicator other than my hover state. That's telling me.
Kostantino: Ideally. Why wouldn't we change those colors? You know, for instance, right now it's that greenish, yellowish
Kostantino:  why wouldn't we turn it into a bright pink or a bright orange when I hover over it? Maybe those colors change when I actually engage with it.
Kostantino:  so
Kostantino: I am now in a part that I think says or should say, meet your instructor.
Kostantino: It's building
Kostantino: course. Don't mind.
Kostantino: Oh, little bit.
Kostantino: I would typically have some challenges with this black on this kind of mustardy green. yellow.
Kostantino: Okay, so here's a challenge. I am scrolling right to left, so that I could try and get over and quote unquote, meet my instructor. But I can't seem to do that
Kostantino: now. It looks like we have the video play option here.
Kostantino: Yeah, it's not scaling. The responsiveness of it is definitely a challenge.
Kostantino: Excuse me for that hip-hop.
Kostantino:  I'm gonna come back.
Try and
Kostantino: meet your instructor.
Kostantino: I'm Kate. Oh, Kate Kalsavets, Hello, Kate, good to see you hopefully.
Kostantino: okay. So here's our video.
Kostantino: I think that says, Oh, probably. Say, I think I saw the word meet. So meet my instructor right?
Kostantino:  Now, what I know from some of our upscale training is that
Kostantino: we have the option to deal with descriptions.
Kostantino: And then we have the video transcript, which is great, fantastic.
Kostantino: So I'm gonna try and come back to the single.
Kostantino: All right. Okay, I was really worried that some of that responsiveness was not kicking in.
Kostantino: But Comichiwa, it has definitely kicked in here. So you can see my comfort level with this single format orientation.
Kostantino: I really really like it. And
Kostantino: here is where we would be able to go through all of the elements. I'd be able to come down. I like the fact that I can. That's great. I could just touch anywhere on the screen to stop and start
Kostantino: I'm gonna have the same problem with the video that I mentioned earlier with the icons. It's very, very bright. Just gonna quickly command control option. 8 out
again.
Kostantino: We've got that same problem.
Kostantino: So
Kostantino: when I come out of it, it's a bright white when I'm in it. And I started
Kostantino: going past that first black screen once I get into any part of the content, or it starts the entire back part of the screen right now for me is a bright, bright, bright, bright, bright, bright white, with, I think, some
Kostantino: red text on there
Kostantino: can can deal with it. The good part for me is that you know as much as I'd love to see the lovely and amazingly talented Kate. I'm more about the content, so it would be more about listening to what's going on.
Kostantino: I also am a very big note taker, and as a result of those notes being able to quickly come back into my browser and touching anywhere on the video allows me to stop it so that I can quickly do what I want with my notes and then go back to it.
Kostantino: If I really wanted to take my time and and and absorb all of the content. Make sure that I don't miss a word. I would definitely go down to the video transcript side of things.
Kostantino: So,
Kostantino: what is a challenge is that you have to be directly over that element?
Kostantino:  So I'm gonna tell you as the learning manager.
Kostantino: I'm impressed, and I think that this is the kind of flow that we would be going for or through. I could probably go back to the other courses and try and determine some items.
Kostantino: But our biggest issues were really some of the map bars or the sidebar that we had where that content was disappearing once we were using the command plus minus keys. If we were using pinch to zoom.
Kostantino: we didn't have a change if I used my option, command 8.
Kostantino: I didn't have a change, but because I was magnified at at such a high level, much more difficult to try and navigate through. Would this be a platform that I would like my team to work with 100? It is definitely
Kostantino: the kind of layout and configuration that I think would help a lot of disabled users in my case with magnification. I do have the responsiveness with the Hover text, although, as I mentioned, it, has to start at the top and not at the bottom.
Kostantino: I would also, in closing. suggest that
Kostantino: if there is an option to put in maybe a
Kostantino: simple
Kostantino: setting within my preferences that would maybe remove some of the content that's not required and maybe simplify it to text. Only that would really help.
Kostantino: I also happen to be a user that would be more than fine, with all black on all, or white or
Kostantino: inverted for me all white on that black
Kostantino: if those options existed, I would definitely be taking advantage of them overall. But
Kostantino:  Being able to come back to  courses
Kostantino: hopefully.
Kostantino: Oh, I don't know. Okay, there we are. So we're back to the landing page. Really nice, simple navigation menu up top. I'd like to see courses in front of dashboard for alphabetical and logical reasons.
Kostantino: got a hamburger that transforms over on the right for the user and the pulldown for preferences settings.
Kostantino: but the active courses, the journey, and then the bookmarks. All of that section tends to disappear at this level. And I'm just gonna go in
Kostantino: one last time.
Kostantino: Yeah, it seems to have gone for me. I could spend a little bit of time trying to look at it. But II think that's I think that's what happened. So is it usable and understandable
Kostantino: absolutely? Are there a couple of small issues that I think are. you know, potentially larger issues, but not monstrous.
Kostantino: and their relatively quick fixes.
Kostantino:  what are my aus thoughts on this? It probably gonna be pretty hot because fable has done a great job here on the upscale side of things.
Kostantino: of simplifying things, of really providing a user with the options that make sense. And everything did seem to make sense for me, except for some of the issues that I pointed out. So
Kostantino: with that
Kostantino: I would say, thank you so much, fable for giving me the opportunity to provide some of my feedback and my lived experience and trying to navigate the upscale side or this new Qa version of it
Kostantino: and thank you for doing everything that you do typically with clients. I would thank them for working for us
Kostantino: or with us. but in my case I have to thank fable for working for the entire disabled community.
Kostantino: What you do and how you do it is absolutely incredible, and I have an enormous amount of pride and joy. Being part of the fable, team and family that is making accessibility happen for millions of people around the world. Keep up the great work, and have yourself a great day.